hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys levels
heute gibt es eine richtig leckere
sommerliche torte demokrat hat
sommertraum torte genannt romande
amerikas schlicht pakistan wird immer
titelbild von brigitte will sich ja
eigentlich schon
also eine richtig schöne sommerliche
frische torte ich habe einen biskuitteig
mit bisschen haselnüssen und mandeln und
darin ist eine marmoriert frischkäse
creme denkt vielleicht auch frischkäse
ist nicht so lecker aber in der torte
schmeckt wirklich sehr gut
ich habe da ganz viele für frische
saisonale früchte mit eingearbeitet und
die torte ist supereinfach in der
herstellung und auch wirklich sehr
schnell gemacht wenn ihr zum beispiel
den teig am vorabend schon macht könnt
ihr am nächsten tag die torte fertig
stellen und sie dann auch gleich
verlieren
am sonntag machen die truppe kann man
natürlich auch aber ich finde es immer
ganz praktisch wenn man sehr farben
macht dann kann man nämlich den tag
einfach über nacht ausruhen lassen und
kann ihn dann besser durchschneiden aber
man kann wie gesagt alles auch im
gleichen tag machen ich sage jetzt erst
mal die zutaten für den teig den war
dies nämlich zuerst herstellen
und ja deswegen starten wir direkt fit
ist brauchen wir zwei eier 2 esslöffel
heißes wasser etwas vanille extrakt
unter prise salz 60 gramm zucker jeweils
35 grad speisestärke und mehl 1
teelöffel backpulver 50 kommt sagt peter
schokolade die habe ich bereits gehabt
ich habe ich 50 gramm mandeln die sind
gestiftet und 60.000 city habe ich auch
bereits fein gemahlen
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die eier
und geht sie in einer rührschüssel da
kommt doch was passiert das so einfach
ist das ein ganz normaler mitgeteilt ein
bisschen vanille extrakt
zucker und salz jetzt wird die macher
für etwa vier bis fünf minuten cremig
verwirrt
die eier zuckermasse sieht sehr cremig
aus und ist auch sehr voluminös da kommt
jetzt die trockenen zutaten rein und
damit die keine klümpchen bilden gebe
sie durchziehen
dann auch gleich die restlichen zutaten
also schokolade machen und die haben wir
jetzt alles kurz mit einem schneebesen
unterheben
und den teig film eine vorbereitete
backform darf jetzt einen tortenring auf
20 cm eingestellt
und so wird der teig jetzt bei 190 grad
ober unterhitze im vorgeheizten backofen
etwa 20 minuten gebacken und danach
lassen abkühlen
der whisky zeigt ist abgekühlt und jetzt
kann ich die füllung zu bereiten ich
habe einmal eine frischkäse creme und
die werde ich nochmal moore ihren mit
einer früchte einlage
ich brauche an zutaten 300 gramm gemüse
früchte da habe ich jetzt johannisbeeren
himbeeren kirschen bromberg und
heidelberg
ich habe ein päckchen magazine oder agar
agar 100 milliliter wasser 100 gramm
zucker und für die creme brauche ich 300
gramm frischkäse 450 gramm puderzucker
etwas vanille extrakt eine millimeter-
und etwas rabatt sei es nämlich jetzt
die früchte und die könnt ihr wirklich
un mission sowie ihr gerne möchte und
einfache früchte der saison nehmen
jetzt nehme ich die ganzen früchte und
wetzt verlesen
die kirche muss ich in steinen die
heilquellen kann ich jetzt direkt in den
topf geben die werden jetzt gleichauf
gekocht und es wird eigentlich wie so
eine art rote grütze die hannes band
sich vom stil herunter
ein
zu den früchten kommt jetzt noch das
wasser da muss ich die früchte erst mal
durch probieren es geht am besten mit
einem pürierstab oder falls einen mixer
habt könnt ihr jetzt auch in einem mixer
machen
und beim pürieren müsse darauf achten
dass sie entweder ein gefäß nie etwas
hoch genug ist
ich habe jetzt leider kein höheres mehr
weit da die sahne schon drin steckt oder
ihr nehmt eben den tropf und haltet den
schief und tauchte nix starb ganz einer
spritze nicht aber ihr solltet dabei
einer der kameramann angucken sonst
verklickert ihr das alles hat mich
abgelenkt weil
jetzt kommt hier noch der zucker mit
amazon und ihr könnt es jetzt
abschmecken falls ihr das jetzt nicht so
süß haben wollt gebt ihr nur ein
bisschen zucker rein
falls ihr süßes haben möchte gerne den
ganzen zug es kommt da einfach drauf an
wie süß schon die früchte waren die er
benutzt dann noch die ak tiere die wir
das ganze dann gleich gut binden
jetzt fürchtet einmal kurz durch und
lass es dann für mindestens zwei minuten
sprudelnd aufkochen
dürfte die mischung zwei minuten lang
sport und aufkochen das ist auch ganz
wichtig damit die alpine ihre wirkung
entfaltet jetzt werde ich sie durch ein
sieb streichen
so gehen die kerne weg ihr könnt sie
aber auch drin lassen wenn ihr wollt so
schmeckt sie nur etwas feiner
kann ich diese mischung kurz zur seite
stellen
sie muss jetzt erstmal abkühlen und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
krieg vorbereiten dafür nehme ich jetzt
die sahne und gibt da vier teelöffel
sein apartment dazu und schlagt die
sahne steif
die sahne sitzt stein
jetzt kann ich noch die frisch käsecreme
22 käse den puderzucker etwas vanille
extrakt und den limiten abrieb in der
schüssel
wir können jetzt hier aber
beispielsweise auch zitrone nehmen aber
ich finde die mitte passt geschmack ich
auch so
jetzt kommt noch ein limettensaft mir
dazu von der ganzen limette
jetzt hier noch drei teelöffel seiner
partei immer pro 100 gramm atze kommt
ein teelöffel mit dazu jetzt wird es
ganz kurz berührt
und jetzt kann ich die sahne hier noch
unterheben
ganz vorsichtig seid könnt es auch kurz
mit dem schneebesen machen
nur dürfe jetzt nicht zu lange rühren
damit die sahne nicht gerinnt von
schaeffler keine frischkäse creme
sondern eine buttercreme
jetzt muss ich nur noch kurz auf die
frucht ein lager warten bis sie zimmer
warm ist
das heißt bis ich sie anfassen kann und
sie nicht mehr warm ist und solange
stelle ich die creme ist in den
kühlschrank und dann geht's gleich
weiter
die frucht ein lager ist das zimmer
rahmen jetzt kann ich schon mal den
tortenboden vorbereiten
und der ist er wie gesagt schon
abgekühlt jetzt ziehe ich den offenen
torten retter und kann jetzt mit einem
tortenring messer den tortenring
entfernen
kann ich den tortenboden mit dem torten
retter unternehmen und den dann einmal
griechischen halten
den unteren taten boden den lege ich
jetzt auch eine tortenplatte und sagten
sie ist ein sauberer tortenring
drumherum
jetzt nehme ich die torten creme und
geht jetzt die frucht ein lager immer in
so kleinen klecksen obendrauf und
deswegen darf jetzt auch nicht mehr warm
oder heiß sein und so wird die creme
dann gleich marmoriert
habe ich erstmal nur die hälfte der
frucht einen marke drin nämlich den
schneebesen und memory sie ganz leicht
das heißt ich mache ganz leichte
drehbewegungen und so vermischt sich die
creme mit der frucht einlage
jetzt kann man die creme gleich schon
ein film und schön darauf achten dass
dieser monierte effekt noch erhalten
bleibt
die
und jetzt am besten gar nicht groß
verstreichen sondern nur ein bisschen
schieben damit sich die torten creme
gleichmäßig verteilt
die restlichen kleckse gebe ich jetzt
auch noch einen drauf und jetzt kommt
der torten deckel drauf und damit kann
man die creme ist auch schön glatt
drücken
jetzt kommt da einen toten retter drauf
und dann muss die torte für mindestens
vier bis fünf stunden erst mal in den
kühlschrank
die tat bis jetzt gut gekühlt und jetzt
kann sie dekoriert werden
darauf gibt nur noch ganz wenige zutaten
ich habe hier bereits 100 gramm sahne in
einen topf die last jetzt kurz aufkochen
und da kommen gleich 50 gramm zucker
schokolade mit rein und da wird es wie
so eine art schokosoße und die gebe ich
dann gleich hier drüber der zwischenzeit
kann ich jetzt schon mal ganz kurz den
torten rahmen entfernen
den tortenring aber eben ein auge auf
die sahne haben dass die nicht überkocht
dann wie gesagt in herausstellen
schokolade einrühren und so lange bis c
geschmolzen ist
magath ich habe eigentlich das
falschgeld ist genau ich muss 100 gramm
schokolade und 100 gramm sahne nehmen 50
mit rein
denn so wie die schokosoße jetzt ein
bisschen zu flüssig als ich mich dass
die schon bisher fester wird was so ein
bisschen cremigen so was halt die
perfekte soße für waffe zum kunde muss
nur zart wieder schokoladen nehmen muss
nicht aber ich habe ja schon in meinem
teig mit drin
deswegen passt jetzt auch ganz gut aber
wenn wir zum beispiel eine weiße
schokolade nehmt dann könnt ihr auch
jetzt hier eine weiße schokolade
jetzt kommt die schokoladensauce auf die
torte als die beteiligten ein bisschen
erstmal in der mitte kommt da gleich die
früchte draufzukleben sie schön an und
dann kommst du nicht immer über die
früchte über das mich interessiert die
kinder auch immer diese werbung mit
dieser schokolade war so schön runter
läuft und das ist möglichkeiten auf
erdölbasis ein freund gemacht gesagt der
fotos macht es wird nicht auf erdölbasis
gemacht es ihnen werben damit ich so aus
aber natürlich er sich essen und bauen
sich alles nicht gefällt oder ja das
alles echt
schütze oder torte die du gerne mag sie
sehr einfach zu machen ist und grandios
schmeckt ja und gegensatz zu einer
veganen trotte ziel zutaten noch günstig
also dass diese torte hat bei mir das
schwäbischen tabelle von 15 wenn 1
günstig ist und fünf teuer
ich glaube es wäre auch mal 3 die
restliche summe die hebel sitzt auf die
bekommt dann jeder einfach auf seinen
teller mit drauf ich stelle jetzt noch
mal ganz kurz kühl
du kannst schon 88 die man sich ganz
vergessen ich hab ich nämlich noch
gestiftete mandeln habe ich in der
pfanne ohne fett etwas gerösteten
abkühlen lassen und die kommen jetzt
noch mit obendrauf denn wir haben dir
auch mit dem teig drin das heißt hier
oben haben jetzt auch noch mal schön
crunch supermacht das kommt macht und
noch wissen
jetzt kann ich die torte anschneiden
nicht sagen dass jetzt sogar bisserl weh
weil er fürchtete mich so schön aber ich
gehe einfach für durch und die torten im
übrigen ist jetzt mit wieder mal zu
freunden ganz in grün eingeladen ging es
auch bei allen die chance dass es klappt
und ob man nur seit die regierung zu
freuen wenn wir sie besuchen gehen weil
viele fragen im hab ich jeden tag
besucht die haben natürlich nicht aber
wie sie halt oft auch die liebe zum
essen eingeladen zu werden und sollen
zum essen zu gehen also das ist wobei
ich habe auch freunde die laden mich
nicht zum essen einmal sagen für die
sally will ich jetzt nicht kochen
dabei bin ich amazonas wählerisch kamen
im rat so nicht ob sich die spitze
ausgesetzt und diese diese größe zeigt
er was bedeutet dieser dieser
schließlich sollte auch nicht karalus
frauenhänden kekse schokolade drin weil
es hier aussieht
jetzt probiert nur aus sinnvoll die
spitze weg gehen wie ihn also erstmal
hier die brombeere liebe warum er immer
früher im garten gesammelt als kind und
haben uns immer an den beinen sowie
gemacht gibts ja mal hoch wenn meine
zuschauer am essen soll wirklich dass
ich mit diesen markierten effekt ganz
toll
genau das kommt eben durch diese frucht
einlage und zwar wirklich super
zudem trotz käse was sie nach dem weg
machen soll ist eine stille die viel
geld ziemlich stören
ja das sind optisch immer sehr schön
aber bei mir sehr sternsinger tennis
durch die trotz käse fernbleiben
zwischen 10 hängen
aber wirklich genial und er hat mir ganz
so euphorisch der frischkäse creme lag
am super das freut mich am anfang war
das wort immer so ein frischkäse gegner
aber mittlerweile konnte ich ihn davon
überzeugen dass diese cremes eben dann
nicht zu süß schmecken
weil eben dieses leicht salzige die
torte und dieses süße ganz gut
ausgleicht also falls jetzt auch lust
bekommen habt auf diese torte bei murat
und toller verkoster ist und eben alles
so beschreibt dann geht auf meinem blog
cellistin luftloch data steht manchmal
für euch und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nach back der teig ist genial
der store ist quasi das auch so
naschen stück hatte innerhalb von einer
minute irgendwie weggehauen jiabao jetzt
die zwiebeln schälen den ort habe ich
noch meinen lang als drei kilo und mit
dem 8 die schmeckt so lecker sind auch
ein rezept dazu gemacht und fast gar
nicht so toll aber es ist jetzt also
oder deftiger ausgleich jetzt kommt noch
zu packen will mich nicht los ich danke
von zwiebeln durch die maschine und dann
muss man aber auch hätte also viel spaß
zum nächsten mal tschüss